Hi.
My name is Seth Ladd.
I'm a developer advocate with
the Google Chrome team.
Today, we're going to learn
about structured web
programming with Dart,
the new open source
web programming platform.
Our goal is to help developers
from all platforms build
complex, high performance
client apps
for the modern web.
That's a mouthful, let's
break it down.
"All platforms" means that
developers from Android, iOS,
Java, .NET, C#, C++, et cetera,
not just endemic web
developers, should all be
building for the web.
"Complex" means more features,
more functionality, more HTML5
goodness, all integrated
into your app.
There's a tremendous wealth of
new web platform features,
from file systems to WebGL, to
CSS3 that your modern app can
take advantage of.
"High performance"
is easy to spot.
60 frames a second, zero jank,
zero hitching, zero latency.
And of course fast computational
execution.
"Client apps" means we want to
see more business logic, more
functionality living and running
inside of the browser.
Modern web apps use the server
as a JSON restful endpoint,
with the business logic
and functionality
living in the client.
"Modern web" means the rising
number of HTML5 browsers.
Dart targets the modern browser,
which essentially
means only IE9 and above, and
the latest releases of Chrome,
Safari, Firefox, Opera, and
of course, the mobile web
browsers like Mobile Safari
and Chrome for Android.
This presentation will cover
an introduction to the Dart
platform and its motivations.
We'll look at the Dart language,
the different Dart
runtimes and tools, and finish
up with a look at the Dart
community and the
future of Dart.
Let's get started.
Let's begin with a high level
look at the Dart project.
Very importantly, Dart
is open source.
The project is under a
BSD-style license.
We launched the project in
October, 2011, and you can
find the code at
dart.googlecode.com.
We have a contributing guide
to help you send patches.
We've already received
fixes and
features from the community.
Dart is much more than
just a language.
Dart comes batteries included.
Along with the language,
Dart also ships a
wide variety of libraries.
We have a core set of classes
and interfaces for
functionality like dates
collections, and
the built-in types.
We also ship libraries for the
DOM, JSON, UTF, URI, Math,
Crypto, and more.
Dart can run on its own virtual
machine, either on the
command line or in a browser.
We ship a Dart editor, a
lightweight editor that
understands Dart programs
with features like
refactoring and debugging.
We have a custom build of
Chromium with an embedded Dart
VM, affectionately
called Dartium.
This is great for fast
development iterations.
And most importantly, Dart
compiles to JavaScript.
Dart programs work across the
entire modern web thanks to
this compiler.
Compiling to logical, sane, and
performant JavaScript is
incredibly important
for the project.
Dart runs on the client
as well as the server.
Dart runs in web browsers when
compiled to JavaScript, or
directly in browsers that have
the Dart VM embedded.
Dart runs on the server via the
standalone VM, which runs
on the command line and can
interact with sockets, files,
directories, and even
run a web server.
We've seen how developers really
like the power of using
the same language for both
client and server, and we
believe that an end-to-end Dart
solution will be quite
compelling.
Incredibly important is to
remember the Dart targets the
entire modern web.
We can do this with our Dart
to JavaScript compiler.
Using this compiler, you can
convert your Dart app into
modern JavaScript, essentially
ES5 for modern web clients
running on desktops,
laptops and mobile.
Dart is built explicitly
for modern web apps.
These are rich client apps
that are offline-capable.
These modern web apps strive for
a constant 60 frames per
second, and are written for
browsers that support ES5+.
Modern web apps use
the vast number of
advanced HTML5 features.
We're not talking about
interactive sites and pages,
but immersive, fast, modern
apps that users demand.
It's important to understand
that Dart is still in
technology preview.
We launched this project early
to get feedback from the
community to help
us prioritize.
We're still building out the
platform and adding features
and functionality.
You should expect changes ahead
as we refactor, but part
of the fun is to be part
of something early.
Your feedback counts
as we work hard
towards a stable release.
We've just looked at a broad
overview of the Dart project.
Now, let's look at the
motivations and philosophy for
the project.
As we know, web development
is good.
You can experience very fast
iterative development with the
Reload button acting
as your compiler.
You can make a small change,
reload, and see the results
right there.
The web is platform independent,
with seemingly
every device with
a screen these
days using a web browser.
The runtimes themselves are
getting faster and faster.
And modern web browsers
are on the rise.
I like to track how many people
can play Angry Birds in
their browser, because that
game requires a fast
JavaScript engine, hardware
accelerated graphics and an
app cache for offline.
I checked Global Stat Counter
the other day, so take this
with a grain of salt, but
something like 70% of desktop,
laptop, and notebook web users
could play Angry Birds in
their browser.
That's hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of
millions of active users
of modern web browsers.
Impressive.
However, we believe it should
be easier to build the apps
users envision.
We think it should be easier
to understand the program
structure of web apps.
If you think about it, how
do you even know where a
JavaScript program
even starts?
Where is the main method?
We think that it's taken far
too long for decent tool
support to arrive for
web developers.
Developers should have access
to tools that help them find
errors and bugs earlier in
the development cycle.
We think it should be easier
to integrate code across
different frameworks, allowing
developers to build more
complex applications
more easily.
And we think it should be easier
to work with larger
teams, where you can't just tell
someone where to find a
method or what parameters
to pass in.
We think it should be easier to
meet the new user demands
of lickable, beautiful, full
functionality applications
that exploit all the
capabilities of their device.
We think it should be easier
to sidestep the almost 15
years of cruft that has built
up in the platform.
Certainly one of the web's
greatest strengths is that the
original web page still renders
in today's browsers.
However, for developers, there
are a lot of dark corners and
alleyways that we
should avoid.
There's too many old wives
tales out there
that no longer apply.
What would it look like if we
could follow the golden path
more clearly?
So innovation is essential for
the growth of the web.
We think that Dart fills a
vacuum and provides an option
for non-endemic developers who
want to build for the web, as
well as existing web developers
that want to scale
up to bigger, more
complex apps.
I remember a great quote
that came out around
the launch of Dart.
"No one has a monopoly on
innovation." Think about the
full title of the web, "the open
web platform." That first
word, "open," means that anyone
can introduce a new
feature or functionality to the
web, and have a chance to
prove its technical merit and
show how the web is enhanced
by this new feature.
For example, there are features
of the web today that
no-one can imagine
the web without.
The canvas was originally
unilaterally added to the web
by Safari to some outcry, but
today it's enabled some killer
games and apps.
With more developers building
more full-featured, awesome
apps for the modern
web, we all win.
Let's now look at the
Dart language.
You can learn Dart quickly.
Dart as a class-based, single
inheritance, object oriented
language with interfaces.
You can yawn right there, which
is exactly the point.
Dart is familiar.
It is designed to be
recognizable to an army of
existing developers out there.
Everyone from the JavaScript
developer that loves functions
and hasn't seen a type before
all the way to the Java
developers that love building
abstract class
factory class factors.
Dart is a language for
existing developers.
We got dinged a bit when Dart
first launched, because some
people were expecting the
next best Haskell.
We wanted more than five users,
so we designed Dart to
be something that you can learn
and be productive with
with just a short
amount of time.
Here's an example of
some Dart code.
We're showing variables, lists,
iterations, final, and
even string interpolation.
Even with all these features,
I think most developers can
grok this code.
You're seeing the use of a
list literal, the for in
iteration loop, and one of my
favorite features, string
interpolation.
Going a little deeper, here's
an example of Dart functions
and closures.
Even though Dart has class
syntax and semantics, you
don't have to use them.
If you're comfortable with
functions, you can
use them with Dart.
Looking at this code, the type
dev here sets up a function
alias, allowing our tools to
better support when we pass
around functions.
Anytime we can help our tools,
the more chances that we can
be warned about potential
problems and bugs early.
The make adder function is a
top level function which
creates a closure around
N and returns a
function of type pattern.
The main method creates a new
adder function that adds two
to a number.
Dart's functions and closures
make it easy to compose
programs without classes.
Even though you don't have
to use classes, there are
situations where you're really
glad you have them.
For example, today, it's very
difficult to share code across
JavaScript frameworks.
It's clear that many developers
think in classes
and want to work with classes,
and most of the major
JavaScript libraries provide
a way to emulate classes.
Here, you are looking at four
different ways to make a class
with MoodTools, Prototype,
Dojo, and ExJS.
A class from one library cannot
be shared with a class
from another library.
This limits the ability to
compose systems with multiple
libraries and frameworks.
In Dart, you can share and
structure code across
libraries and frameworks thanks
to class and interface
semantics built right
into the language.
Here, you are looking at
a simple point class.
A favorite feature is the
constructor arguments sugar.
The this.x and this.y
constructor arguments desugars
into this.x equals x, and this.y
equals y, a common
pattern in most constructors.
On the right is an example of
a panel class from framework
A, and a menu class from
framework B that cleanly
extends the panel from framework
A. This is an
example of two separate
libraries sharing code and
building on one another.
This leads to more code reuse.
In Dart, you can reason about
unfamiliar code more easily.
For example, the JavaScript
example at the top reads, the
calculate method takes an
origin, an offset, an
estimate, and I don't even
know what it returns.
What is an origin?
What is an offset?
What does this return?
Given this function signature,
you know almost nothing.
Of course, you can pray the
developer left comments that
annotate all the types of the
parameters and return value.
If you're lucky, they did.
But then your tools don't know
how to parse written text.
Worst case, you're reading the
function body, and if you're
reading the function body,
you've broken encapsulation,
and you're in a bad spot.
You really want to know what
the method is, what you can
pass to it, and what
it can return.
With Dart's optional type
annotations, you can add
inline types to better convey
your intention to fellow
developers, and give the tools
to help you detect problems
and bugs early.
Optional static type annotations
is a long term,
but it simply means you can use
static types when you want
to, and leave them out
when you don't.
We created a system that helps
you without getting in your
way, a system that doesn't
create an overly burdensome,
ceremonial type checker.
Dart's types create an innocent
until proven guilty
programing experience.
Dart supports duck typing, but
there are plenty of cases
where you want inline
documentation for the
consumers of your API and
tool-based checks.
We'll see how optional type
annotations help us scale our
code from small ideas
to large apps.
Let's look at an example now.
To the Dart Editor!
This is the standalone
Dart Editor.
It ships with the
Dart project.
Let's use it to write some
simple Dart code.
Let's say that you want to write
a game, and you want two
figures to battle.
Let's see how that might look.
First, we're going to write a
main method, and let's say
that we want those two figures
to equip for battle, so equip
for battle.
And I guess they're warriors.
And we want to do
warrior.equip.
And let's say we're going
to give him a new sword.
Cool.
So I save my project.
And immediately, my editor gives
me real-time feedback.
It says, can't find sword.
Doesn't know what a sword is.
Well, that's great.
I know before I even run
the program what
else I need to do.
So let's create a sword class.
Very cool.
So now in our main method, let's
create these warriors.
Well, it's pretty fun to have
pirates and ninjas battle, so
let's make a pirate first.
I'm going to say
equipforbattle(new Pirate()).
And sure enough, my editor again
tells me, I don't know
what a pirate is.
Let's go ahead and make him
happy and create a pirate.
All right.
OK, so let's just run
this program.
Right away, the runtime says,
can't find method equip on
instance of pirate.
Well, he's right.
I look, the pirate doesn't
have equip.
If only my tools could
have told me this.
But let's go ahead, and let's
make the program happy.
We'll say it takes a weapon and
we'll say "arg." When I
run the program again,
everything works and "arg" is
printed out, exactly
as we'd expected.
But Dart lets us do better.
And now that we have a little
bit more comfort that we have
these things called warriors,
and they get equipped with
these things called weapons, we
can begin to solidify the
design a little bit.
Now, we need to things
to battle, so
let's create a ninja.
OK.
And I'm going to be a little
bit smarter this time.
If you are reading this,
you're already dead.
OK.
But I want my tools to warn me
before I run the program if
there's any potential problems.
And this is where
the optional static type
annotations come into play.
I'm more comfortable now that I
have pirates and ninjas, and
they're both warriors.
So let's tell the program
that they're warriors.
We'll create an interface.
And we'll give it a weapon.
Interfaces define just the
contract for a class.
And we'll say a pirate
is a warrior.
We'll say that a ninja
And finally, we're going to
tell equip for battle to
expect that a warrior is
actually a warrior.
And now, if I remove some code
here, my program can tell me a
warning before I even run that a
ninja can't really be passed
in here, because it's missing
some methods that are going to
be called inside
equipForBattle.
This is great, immediate,
instant feedback that my
system can tell me before
I even run.
So I add that code back.
The program's very happy.
Those warnings go away.
And certainly, "if you're
reading this, you're already
dead" and "arg" are
printed out.
That's great.
So we've shown now how we can
scale from a system that
doesn't use optional static
type annotations up to
actually using the type
annotations and how they give
us these early warnings.
This is great, but then you
might be thinking, doesn't
this lock me into some
heavyweight design now?
How do I move fast?
How do I iterate?
How do I develop further?
Well again, you can scale up and
you can scale back down.
So let's just use one
more example here.
Let's say that I want to
introduce the wildcard to my
battle and introduce a zombie.
OK.
So if I go ahead and add a
zombie class here, and let's
say he takes a weapon.
And I'll print, silly, a
zombie's weapon is his
insatiable lust for
human flesh.
Now, my program is going to run,
but it's giving me these
warnings here.
And I'm not certain that
a zombie is a warrior.
A warrior has a code, and
zombies have no code.
I want my program
to run anyway.
I don't want to have to somehow
jam in a class into
some particular hierarchy just
to satisfy the system.
And so I can pull the type
annotations back off, thus
making the program more happy.
And I can run here.
The program runs and terminates
correctly.
You can see that a zombie
is equipped.
But you've see how we can start
without static type
annotations, create
a program as we're
flushing out a design.
As we get more comfortable with
it, we can add the type
annotations, and the system
gives us that early feedback
and the early warnings.
And then later on if you're
doing some refactorings, or
you need to manipulate the
program structure, you can
pull some of the type
annotations off, reducing the
amount of warnings, even
though you know it's
all going to run.
And then later, when you get
more comfortable, you can add
the type annotations back on.
That's that scalability story
that we talked about.
Now, let's turn our attention
to the JavaScript puzzler
section of the talk.
In Dart, you can rely on
this not changing.
Thanks to Dart's lexical scope,
we know exactly which
method will be called, given
only the program structure.
We no longer have to capture
this and assign it to that.
In this example here, when a
button is clicked, the cool
method is called on this for
the instance of awesome.
This is the behavior that
developers expect from their
programming language.
In Dart, you can expect
sane for loops.
If you know JavaScript, you
might know what happens if you
run this code.
Here we have a for loop
iterating over values of i,
and giving them to closures
to be called later.
When the code calls the
callbacks, JavaScript will
print two and two, which
is quite surprising.
Dart's for loops have sane
semantics for capturing values
inside of closures.
In Dart, the program outputs
zero and one, which is exactly
what you would imagine.
Creating readable method
calls is easy in Dart.
You've seen those methods that
take one or more Booleans at
the end, resulting in
hard to grok code.
Try reading flipped flags.
True, false, true?
True what?
False what?
Thanks to Dart's named
parameters, you can say what
you mean more easily.
On is true, up is false,
hidden is true.
Got it.
A benefit of named parameters
is that they become optional
if you give them a
default value.
Here, hidden is default to
false, which means you can
leave it out, like the
last example shows.
A theme here is to make it
easier to write code
understandable by humans and
machines, plus integrating
more code into more
complex apps and
catching issues early.
Web developers know
that you never
block the main UI thread.
This example is something
you never do.
You never put lengthy or
costly methods back
to back like this.
The common way to split up the
work is to use callbacks that
trigger the next step
in the algorithm.
These callbacks fire when the
event loop is ready, thus
giving the UI thread a chance
to do other work.
However, as you can see, these
callbacks get nasty and
nested, making it
hard to read.
Deeply nested and async code
becomes hard to follow.
Luckily, in Dart, you
can use a future to
encapsulate this pattern.
A future is a promise for a
value to be provided later.
If each of the costly methods
return a future as a token,
you can chain the methods,
as shown here.
These methods now line up and
become easier to read, yet
still run asynchronously.
A future is returned
immediately, and when it has a
value, its chain method
is called.
Or then is called when the
last future has a value.
The future API is beginning to
show up in more and more Dart
code as the preferred
alternative to one-shot callbacks.
One of the core tenets of Dart
is that it must compile to
JavaScript.
As you know, JavaScript
is single threaded.
But as you also know,
devices are shipping
with multicore machines.
Concurrency is great, but
shared memory threads is
error-prone and hard
to optimize.
Dart programs can take advantage
of multicore through
a system called isolates.
An isolate is an isolated memory
heap that can run in a
separate thread or process.
Because there is no shared
state, you communicate between
isolates by passing messages.
Here is an example
of spawning an
isolate for an echo function.
A send port is returned, which
is used to send "hello from
Maine" and wait for a reply.
The use of then is a
signal that we're
using the future library.
You can see the echo function
waits for messages on its
receive port, and replies to
those messages are sent with
the send function.
Even though Dart is a familiar
language, we took this rare
opportunity when designing a
new language to fix a few
things along the way.
Isolates simplifies concurrent
programming.
They were inspired by Erlang's
processes model for safer,
easier to reason about
parallel programming.
The Dart VM natively supports
isolates, and isolates compile
to Web workers for HTML5 apps.
We saw this example when we
played with optional static
type annotations.
The important point to remember
is that the type
annotations aren't there
to get in your way .
You can still write dynamic
duck typed code.
This is especially useful when
you're experimenting or
testing ideas.
You can get even more dynamic-er
with Dart thanks to
noSuchMethod.
If a method isn't resolved on
an object, you can implement
noSuchMethod and dynamically
handle it.
For example, this code exposes
any Json map as a Dart object,
and uses noSuchMethod to handle
the properties of the
Json map as object methods.
Dart is very much a dynamic
scripting language.
We looked at a lot of cool
language features and
improvements over JavaScript.
Let's see how you can
run Dart code.
First up, running Dart
on the server.
Dart isn't just for modern web
apps running on the client.
Dart can also run via its
standalone VM on the command
line for scripts and servers.
This example code serves static
files via the built-in
HTTP server library.
You can also see uses of files
and directories, critical
functionality for command
line apps.
The Dart VM supports a lot
of functionality for your
servers, such as files,
directories, sockets, web
servers, HTTP clients,
and even web
socket servers and clients.
We believe in a vision of
running Dart code on the
client and the server.
Let's see a demo of
this right now.
We're back in the Dart Editor.
Let's look at a simple
Dart server.
This looks familiar to decode
on the slide previously.
Let's make a small change so we
know that it's all working.
Hello:Intertubes.
Save the program.
Our editor is happy.
Let's go ahead and commit
the change.
And now, let's send it
up to the cloud.
This command is actually pushing
the Dart application
you just saw in the editor
up to Heroku's cloud.
Heroku lets you run arbitrary
applications in the cloud.
We've wired in the Dart Virtual
Machine as one of
those runtimes.
So you see here the
deployment process
happening in real time.
Let's grab the URL from
our new Dart app.
Zoom in.
Hello:Intertubes, sure enough
is printed out.
What you're seeing here is
debug outputs from a live
running Dart Virtual Machine
program in the cloud.
We deployed it in real time, and
this is running right now.
Of course, Dart is first
and foremost a
web programming language.
Let's look at Dart running
on the client.
Every web developer is familiar
with the DOM.
Unfortunately, the DOM is a
language agnostic interface,
and never feels natural to
whatever language you're
working in.
JQuery is popular in part
because it did a great job
smoothing over the DOM and
making it feel natural to
JavaScript developers.
Our fresh approach to web
programming means we can take
a fresh approach to interfacing
with the browser.
We've created an HTML library
to make programming the
browser feel like Dart code.
This example shows some of the
HTML library's features.
Creating a new element is simple
thanks to the use of
element.tag named
constructors.
And elements classes are just a
Dart list. So you can add a
new class just like you can add
anything else to any Dart
list.
The event handler is one
of my favorites.
On dot click dot ad reads
clearly and uses an anonymous
function to handle
the click event.
Finally, we easily add the
button to the body's elements,
because elements is just another
Dart collection.
The compiler targets ES5
JavaScript, essentially modern
web browsers.
Work has begun to perform tree
shaking and dead code
elimination, helping apps
load and start quickly.
The compiler itself is
written in Dart.
In fact, you can use the
compiler to compile the
compiler to JavaScript.
We're working hard on generating
smaller and smaller
JavaScript and continued
performance improvements.
We've seen how to
run Dart code.
Now, let's look at editing
and debugging Dart code.
The Dart project ships Dartium,
our build of Chromium
that embeds a Dart VM.
Dartium is great for fast
iterations, enabling you to
write Dart code, make edits, and
simply hit Reload to see
the changes.
The Dart Editor is wired into
Dartium for a nice debugging
experience, and Dartium has
begun integrating the dev
tools for Dart.
Let's see a demo now.
Here's the same code that you
just saw on the slide.
Now, I want to show you this
running in two different ways.
First, when we run it natively,
it'll fire up what
we call Dartium.
Dartium is Chromium
with the Dart
Virtual Machine in action.
Sure enough a button appears.
When we click it, it
tells us clicked.
Pretty impressive.
But the real power is the
integration between Dartium
and the editor.
For instance, let's set
a debug break point.
We run the program again, go
back to the editor, and you
can see the program has stopped
right where we set the
break point.
We continue running
the program, the
button is indeed rendered.
So that's pretty cool.
You can debug in the editor.
You can also debug with
the dev tools
integration in Dartium.
So here, let's load up the
source, just to show you that
the programmer running is indeed
the actual Dart code.
Let's set the same breakpoint in
the dev tools and reload in
the browser.
And sure enough, it stops
exactly where we
set the break point.
More functionality will be added
to the dev tools over
time, give you full debugging
and program manipulation
capabilities.
But let's dive deeper.
For instance, in the editor, you
can do symbol refactoring,
like renaming.
Let's rename this button.
Right-clicking on the button.
Let's choose Clickable, and
sure enough, the editor,
thanks to the optional static
type annotations, confined all
uses of the button variable
and renames
everything to Clickable.
Finally, I want to show you
how you can compile this
simple program into JavaScript
and run it
on all modern browsers.
Using the editor, we can go to
Generate JavaScript from the
Tools menu.
This will now run our
Dart to JS compiler.
Now, we can take the URL
running in Dartium.
We'll open up another
editor here.
Here's Firefox.
We paste in the URL.
Sure enough, the same
application loads up and runs.
This is all thanks to a
bootstrap script that we
include with each
Dart project.
The script here, you can see is
both the Dart application
that is the native Dart code
in the script tag.
But right below that is our
Dart.js bootstrap script.
This will detect if your
browser runs the
Dart Virtual Machine.
If not, it will replace the
above Dart script with the
equivalent compiled to
JavaScript version for
browsers that don't have the
Dart VM embedded in them.
So you've seen how using the
editor and our tools, you can
run a Dart program in Dartium
and any modern web browser.
As you just saw, the Dart editor
supports more than just
editing text.
You can jump to definition,
perform simple refactorings,
debug code, and compile
to JavaScript.
The last tool we'll look at
today is Dart's brand new
package manager, affectionately
called Pub.
With Pub you can install third
party packages into your
application.
Pub makes it easy to manage
application dependencies.
Today, Pub will install packages
straight from Git,
but in the future we will set
up pub.dartlang.org to host,
discover, and install
packaged snapshots.
Using Pub is simple.
Step one, declare your
dependencies in a simple yaml
Pub spec file.
Step two, run Pub Install to
download and install the
libraries into your
application.
Step three, import the new
libraries with a new package
colon prefix.
Finally, deploy the kittens!
Let's go to the demo.
We're back in the Dart Editor.
Let's look at the simple web app
that uses three different
packages, cat pics, frames,
and widgets.
Now, you can see the editor
doesn't know anything about
these three different
libraries, so
let's help it out.
We define our dependencies here
with the Pub spec file.
You can see the three different
package names, cat
pic, frame, and widget, and
pointing to their individual
Git repository somewhere
out on the net.
Once we have that configured, we
can go to the command line
inside our application,
and run Pub Install.
This will go out, parse the Pub
spec file, and pull in all
of our dependencies locally,
right next to our project.
Now, going back to our editor,
you can see that the editor
has now resolved the different
packages to their correct
place, and a new packages
directory is now here.
We defined a dependency on three
different packages, but
we have four packages
installed.
This is because one package
itself has a Pub spec file, so
Pub will walk transitive
dependencies.
Now that we have our application
wired up together
and its dependencies resolved,
we can go ahead and run it.
And sure enough, your
life is complete.
You have cat pics in your app.
And you can see the cat pics
themselves, the widgets, and
the frames are now
all rendered.
And we didn't write
any of that code.
All of that code came from third
party dependencies and
libraries out from the net.
This was all just the
tip of the iceberg.
There's a lot more to the Dart
language, libraries,
and tools to cover.
Let's see how to learn more.
Our api.dartlang.org site has
all the API Docs for all the
libraries that ship
with the Dart SDK.
We even have comments enabled
for you to add your own tips
and tricks.
If you know JavaScript, you'll
definitely want to check out
synonym.dartlang.org.
This site maps common JavaScript
idioms, snippets,
and patterns to their
equivalents in Dart.
Everything is in this page, from
using arrays, to numbers,
to functions, even how to work
with the DOM and jQuery.
This site came out of an
internal Google hackathon.
We think you'll find
it useful.
Our Dart language tour takes
you through the language in
much more detail.
This is a good way to get an
overview of the language
without reading the
language spec.
It's a friendly way to
tour the language.
The Dart library tour walks
you through most of the
libraries that ship
with the SDK.
You'll see what you can do
with the core libraries,
isolates, UTF, URI,
Crypto, and more.
For a high-level overview of
the Dart project, check out
this free ebook from O'Reilly.
This is a quick way to learn
about the project from the
10,000 foot level.
As you're learning about the
Dart language, libraries, and
tools, don't forget to join the
growing Dart community.
The community has already
started to publish libraries
covering everything from MVC
frameworks to physics
simulators, to template
libraries.
More recently, we've spotted a
port of PhoneGap to Dart, and
drivers for databases such
as MongoDB and Redis.
One project that really caught
our attention was the Mod Dart
project that embeds
Dart into Apache.
Not only can you run Dart on
Heroku, but now you can run
Dart with perhaps the most
popular web server.
You can tell the world about
your cool new Dart libraries
using Twitter, Google +, blogs,
IRC, our discussion
mailing list, and of course,
stack overflow.
Engineers from the project, as
well as active community
members, hang out on
the mailing list
and these other channels.
Don't hesitate to drop in, say
hi, and ask questions.
So get started with
Dart today.
If you like rich code editors,
download the Dart Editor
bundle, which has everything
you need, including Dartium
and the Dart SDK.
If you like Vi, Emacs, or
TextMate, you can download the
standalone SDK.
Most importantly, please
send us feedback.
Now that you're all plugged into
the Dart community and
writing Dart code, what's next
for the Dart project?
Well, as we mentioned, Dart is
still in technology preview.
Dart is not done, and there
are some cool new features
coming for the project.
Reflection support, an often
requested feature, is
being worked on.
This isn't as simple
as it may sound.
We want to ensure that we can
ship the smallest amount of
code possible over the wire, so
we need a reflection system
that we can use to introspect
and perform intelligent tree
shaking and dead code
elimination.
Also coming are simplifications
to equality,
the Pub Package Manager, method
cascades, shipping Dart
directly in Chrome, and our
UI libraries for web apps.
Other features like class
mixins, also known as traits,
are being discussed
at a high level.
Here's the summary
as we wrap up.
Today, we learned that Dart
compiles to modern JavaScript.
Dart is easy to learn, with type
annotations that fit the
way you work.
We learned that Dart runs on the
client and the server for
an end-to-end programming
experience.
The Dart project is much more
than just a language.
It ships with libraries and
tools like the Dart Editor.
Dart is under active
development, and has an active
and growing community.
Remember, Dart is structured
web programming compatible
with today's web.
Please give it a try and
give us feedback.
Thanks very much, and thanks
for trying Dart.